I'm living here for eight
months because I'm working
in a COVID-19 center to save
my family from the virus.
I try to make a distance from my family.
This is my reason to
live here in the living room.
It's hard that you live in one house,
but you feel as though you live in another place.
Hanna Samson is a nurse
at the St. Paul's hospital in Ethiopia.
Like many
low-income countries,
Ethiopia has struggled to secure vaccines
leaving its frontline workers
in a vulnerable position.
In December 2020, Hanna
contracted the virus
while working at a
COVID-19 treatment center.
They took me in the hospital.
When I arrived at the
Millennium COVID care center
I lost my consciousness because I'm afraid
and everybody is coming
and caring of myself.
And they took me in a high dependency unit.
I spent for the 16 days and
they give me oxygen, they gave
me unexplainable support
for me, they saved my life.
For Hannah and many
other health care workers
in the world's poorest countries
getting a vaccine, hasn't been an option.
I was afraid when I was sick
and when I heard our
colleagues are dying.
It's a difficult time for me, for my family,
for my friends, colleagues.
But a global initiative called COVAX
is trying to ensure that people
in all corners of the world
get access to vaccines.
Because of COVAX
Hanna was able to get vaccinated
and it might be the best bet
for immunizing the rest of the world too.
As rich countries race to
inoculate their populations
poor countries have fallen behind
in the biggest vaccination
campaign in history
and that's a problem for everyone.
Wildly uneven and unfair that's
how the U.N. describes the distribution
of COVID vaccines around the world.
Very few of those doses,
a very small proportion
of them have been used in low
and middle income countries.
There's five or six of these variants
that I would say are of concern out there.
The thing that we worry
about the most, that it
will essentially evade the
protection of the vaccine.
The pandemic has weighed
heavily on developing economies,
take the example of Ethiopia.
It's long been seen as one
of Africa's most
promising economies,
but the country has
a sizeable debt.
At the end of 2019
it's total public foreign
debts stood at $27.8 billion
according to The World Bank.
The pandemic has put pressure
on the healthcare system and the economy,
leading Ethiopia to ask for debt relief
under a G20 program to
help poor countries reeling
under the economic impact of coronavirus.
For many low-income countries,
even before the pandemic
were facing financial
constraints, huge debt loads
and really didn't have
the financial capacity to
negotiate bilateral deals
with the vaccine developers
like developed countries,
Europe and the U.S. were able to.
I've long argued that pandemics
are an evolutionary certainty.
Seth Berkley is the head of Gavi,
the Vaccine Alliance.
He's an epidemiologist
and you know, he's
really devoted, you know
the past year to fighting the pandemic.
He conceived of this COVAX initiative
at Davos in January, 2020, realizing
that when the pandemic really
hit and we had vaccines
the real challenge would be
providing equitable access
to countries that couldn't
afford to buy them on their own.
My job is to try to solve
these problems and put
in place systems to do that.
And so at this Davos
meeting, we heard about
this new epidemic that was going on.
It was early days, we
didn't know if there were
people to people, transmission
but I sat down with Richard Hatchett,
who's the CEO of CEPI,
the Coalition For Epidemic
Preparedness Innovations,
and we discussed what we were doing.
So that really was the
beginning of the collaboration.
Of course, a lot happened since then,
at the end, they focused on the R&D,
we focused on the
procurement and delivery,
and WHO focuses on the
normative side of things.
But we came together working
like we do in the Alliance
with multiple partners.
For the first time
we've seen the whole world
come together at least in name
in terms of COVAX and
wanting to move forward.
More than 190 countries are participating
in the COVAX facility,
the wealthy countries
are participating through
paying for their doses
through this purchasing
pool that COVAX has set up,
while COVAX provides
the low-income countries
with doses for free through money
it is raised from governments,
development agencies,
as well as, private sector contributions.
When we decided to do COVAX,
we didn't have any deals,
we didn't have any money,
we had to go out and raise money.
We had to begin to talk to
manufacturers and of course
to make a deal with a manufacturer
you have to have the finance in place.
COVAX is a huge international effort.
The biggest international effort
since the Paris Climate Accords.
It has required a massive
fundraising effort
from governments around the world.
It's a procurement challenge,
they've had to negotiate deals
with pharmaceutical
companies to secure doses
on timing and delivery
and then at the same time,
they've had to prepare countries
around the world for the
rollout on the ground.
And that is but a huge, you
know, logistical challenge.
The arrival of this particular
vaccine has come as a great
relief to heath workers
and a lot of Ghanians.
COVAX is aiming to deliver 2 billion
doses by the end of the year.
It has so far raised almost $7 billion,
it just came out
with a new initiative to
raise an additional $2 billion.
But there's still a long way to go,
they need more money and
they need more doses.
Is it enough what they have achieved?
Of course it's not but it's
not a question of money
for the time being, it's
a question of what access
to vaccines are
they going to be given
by others so that they can take care
of the majority of the world's population.
What is surprising is
that wealthy countries
haven't donated more to
COVAX given that it's really
in their self-interest,
if the virus continues
to rage in low-income
countries, that will only mean
that it's likely to boomerang
back into the developed world.
New mutant strains will develop
and it will be incredibly hard
to stop COVID in its tracks.
Right now we have a situation
where wealthy countries have
orded many times of the
amount of doses they need.
It's really time now to turn that around
and either begin to make
those doses available
through dose sharing or
to free up the places
in the manufacturing queue
and that will allow doses
to go across the world
get us to a place where
we can end the acute phase
of the pandemic as quickly as possible.
But it's not just the wealthiest
countries complicating COVAX's efforts.
It's been pretty challenging
for COVAX to get its own supplies,
vaccine nationalism is
so front and center.
Vaccine nationalism is a huge challenge
for the COVAX initiative,
it's heavily dependent
on the AstraZeneca vaccine because of its
low cost and easy distribution.
AstraZeneca is producing the vaccine
on its own, as well as through
an independent manufacturer
in India called the Serum Institute.
But India itself is facing
a second way of infections
and has curbed large-scale
exports of the vaccine.
The other challenge that
COVAX faces is its dependency
on the AstraZeneca vaccine,
which has seen these reports
of rare blood clots
associated with the shot.
And that has given rise
to a vaccine hesitancy
around the world.
You've seen reports of people not showing up
and doses going to waste
because of concerns about the
safety of the vaccine,
even though those reports are
exceedingly rare,
I think it does pose a challenge for
rolling out doses worldwide.
There are also major
challenges to produce the
vast quantity of vaccines
needed around the world.
Normally in the world, we use about three
and a half billion
doses of vaccine a year.
If you add flu to that, it
ends up being about 5 billion.
People are talking about trying
to cover the whole world.
That would be another
10 to 15 billion doses
that would have to be done
in the course of this year.
That would be a quadrupling
of global supply.
That is very ambitious not
just for the manufacturing
capacity but also the raw
materials, the supplies,
the staff and so this is a
real challenge for the world.
Pharmaceutical companies
have been criticized
for not releasing their formulas
so that more manufacturers
can produce at scale.
Some say COVAX should be
doing more to pressure them.
Anna Marriott, the health
policy advisor for Oxfam
argues that these manufacturing issues
could have been mitigated by COVAX.
You know, I think right
from the outset COVAX
should have used its enormous leverage.
It could have pushed those
pharmaceutical corporations
to share the vaccine science and know-how.
We know that there are many offers
on the table from
manufacturers, from Bangladesh,
Pakistan to Denmark and Canada
who are coming forward now
and saying we could help
make these vaccines.
If the vaccine science was shared
and the intellectual property rules removed.
If we'd done that much earlier
on those manufacturers
could be helping us now
making those vaccines.
It's certainly not too late,
we do have to act now.
But COVAX argues the issue lies
in teaching other manufacturers
the detailed analytics,
tests, and quality assurance procedures
needed to make the vaccines.
The issue is not for vaccines
that patents are the blocker.
There may be a patent or two,
but those could be gotten
around if one needed to.
The real challenge is can
you get those thousands
of pages of know-how and can
you have those transferred?
Beyond the immediate
manufacturing problems
hampering COVAX's rollout
lies an even bigger problem.
The initiatives donations
will provide doses
that will cover only
about 30% of populations
in low-income countries.
That's nowhere near what's
needed to achieve herd immunity.
Countries like Ethiopia for instance,
is entirely dependent
on the COVAX initiative.
It has something like 110 million people
and so far it's only
administered about 400,000 doses.
So they have a long way to go before
they get anywhere near what, you know
scientists believe is herd immunity
to stop the pandemic in its tracks.
COVAX may not be a silver bullet
to the world's vaccine equity problem,
but ending the pandemic will be
almost impossible without it.
Well, COVAX is this solution to it,
there is no other one.
Tell me which other organization has
tried to bite the bullet here?
Which other organization
has been so ambitious
that they are promising to do everything
that it takes to give a vaccine
also to those who cannot afford it?
There is no other one, so
they have to be supported.
Of course, at the end of the day
the real question now is
will the doses be available?
Will the companies make the doses?
Will as high-income countries
reach a certain threshold
begin to say we'll release some
of the excess doses that we
have and make those available?
And will we be able
to scale up manufacturing?
If we can do that, then
we'll be in a world where
the world has been
protected during a pandemic.
If we can't do that,
we will be in a world
that is very unfair
and very inequitable
and that's exactly what we're
trying to stop through COVAX.